hello we are back with our coverage of
round seven of the sinkfield cup and we
have two very special guests in the
studio we have Natalie McKay and Erin G
who are here to tell us all about the
project Teddy and Friends inclusive
playground and first of all pleasure to
have you here and have how been enjoying
the CH very honored to be here oh
amazing thank you the the Chess World is
a pretty uh special when people who
don't have a lot of familiar familiarity
suddenly come into a studio and go oh my
gosh chess is Big Stuff worldwide
amazing wow yeah and so first of all
like tell us how Teddy and Friends
inclusive playground came about yeah Ain
will tell you a little bit about that
right so I'm Teddy's mom that's pretty
much my only title these days um and
Teddy has a he will be eight in January
he has a form of
acondroplasia um which is the most
common form of dwarfism so growing up it
was very hard for me to take them to a
community playground um just because
they are not some of them more adaptable
but not inclusive enough and so it was
very hard um until one day last July
where I met um some of my colleagues um
friends who have kids with dwarfism as
well in the Community we met out at
Natalie's first playground called
Zachary's um near Lake St Louis and it
the day was it was perfect we were there
for more than two hours which is very
hard and so he after we get in the car
and Teddy's like Mom that was the best
play date ever and I'm like it really
was but tell me more why why he goes I
could do everything and you didn't have
to help me cuz only have to be you know
lifting them up on the playround helping
with ladders and he goes and you were
able to talk with other moms and because
normally I'm not able to engage with the
other moms on U our playgrounds in our
community just because I'm helping Teddy
so much so I'm like all right buddy I
get it I get it so next day I researched
and researched and found that it was um
a playground done by unlimited play um
and Natalie is locally so I gave her a
call and kind of organically started
from there she's like where would you
like to build and I'm like well I live
in the Town and Country depair West
County area and there's currently not a
playground within 20 miles plus around
like yours and so let's start from there
how does chess connect so how does chess
connect so the theme of The Playground
FasTrack a a little bit um the theme of
The Playground is game board so uh Teddy
and I got on a phone a zoom call with
little Tes commercial who creates um um
the playground um and they're like what
theme do you want I'm like oh goodness I
never thought about that like what does
Teddy like to do and I'm like well he
likes golf tennis chess is a big one and
board games those are his four things
and they're like board games will be fun
and so and chess could be related to it
so right it's kind of how it started and
so Teddy is big in um he's only in
second grade so he's been playing since
kindergarten but he plays in local chess
tournaments and so I'm like well this
will be perfect we first started out um
when we reached out to St Louis chess
club is um our Splash Pad will be chest
themed what's a splash pad um water
feature that kids can run in in and out
of
Fountain okay and the flooring the
structure will be in a chess board ah
fast forward after um some conversations
with members from the St Louis um chess
club okay um it will be turned into
after um in the fall it will be turned
into a big large like they do down um in
Central West and an outdoor chess um
board right gotcha with life-size pieces
to use for uh the community to use our
lessons so so that's your unlimited
playground that's where the whole
concept of the unlimited play unlimed
play is the nonprofit I started and we
build playgrounds like this Across the
Nation now can you tell us what
playgrounds look like right here we've
got some uh sure this is the design for
Teddy and friends so when you watch
there's ramping all the way from the
bottom to the top to the tallest slide
my son was born with a disability and
uses a wheelchair so you can navigate
this entire playground with a Mobility
device of any kind lots of features for
kids with autism to play safely and
enjoy what they're doing that connect
four piece has um holes that are closer
together for people like Teddy who just
need um smaller spaces there and we
design it to make sure every single
child is challenged at their own level
so it's not just for kids with
disabilities but look at all the
climbing it's so beautiful so
colorful I mean it's really so much
thought the themes and how thoughtful
this is and how this can certainly
improve the confidence of all the Young
and with the chess theme you've got a
chess board somewhere in one of those
Water Park area kind of splash pads we
do yes this is f how many parks like
this are there around the world around
the United States pardon me uh unlimited
play is built almost 100 and we probably
have another 20 under design right now
fantastic thank you how do people
support uh your effort supporting Teddy
here locally would be fabulous so we of
course are raising money we raised gosh
the budget it's 3.2 million and we have
1 million left to go we have a gentleman
who's going to match 400,000 of that
right so that can help us in kind labor
concrete site work and then for
unlimited play you can find us on our
website what is your website
unlimited.org and a lot of communities
need playgrounds just like this so out
and let us know and uh when do you hope
to have the Teddy's playground finished
that is such a
good if it was up to me it would be
tomorrow yesterday yesterday yeah I like
that better yesterday right yeah you
right now we have enough money to put
the equipment on order so we'll put it
on order and then we're raising funds
that 1 million that is going to do all
of the infrastructure and site work as
soon as we have that we hope to
in the fall but it takes viewers and
people like you guys to make sure this
happens
wonderful absolutely thank you what a
project I am inspired I think that's
really really beautiful what You' done
you what I've learned there was one
gentleman I was talking to about Chess
and his child has autism and he said
Natalie my son this is his International
Language right it's how he communicates
and it's how I feel about playground
play is that International Language
right that kids can understand and learn
to play together yeah I can just see
Aaron also like you teddy comes and he
sees his Park and the smile oh
absolutely I mean that's that's that's
worth all of it right there right for
him just to do things independently
especially for kids with any limitation
just to be able to play independently
with a parent or an aid is huge for them
it gives them a lot of
confidence one of the reasons tuai also
loves chess is something that he can do
honestly independently is a big one for
him exactly so Challenge and win woohoo
oh yes he loves it lovely thank you both
for uh coming on it was really really
nice and great success with the project
oh my gosh and for teddy as well there
you go thank you thank you thank you
Peter thank you very tell us what's
going on uh in the uh standings at the
moment